hello everyone welcome to um this
meeting of the council
I'm councilor James Caston chairman of
mid-suffolk District Council and I'll be
chairing the meeting today
may I first remind you of some domestic
Arrangements toilets are situated
outside of the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the Ipswich
Town Football Club training pitch do not
re-enter the building until you are told
it's safe to do so and could you please
silence all mobile phones and laptops
please
I would like to remind everyone present
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except when
they're confidential or exempt items if
you make a representation to this
meeting you are you will be deemed by
the council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes the
council members of the public and press
May record film photograph or broadcast
this meeting when the public and the
present press are not lawfully excluded
and will start the agenda thank you
so item one is apologies for absence
okay thank you
thank you um item two is Declarations of
Interest by councilors because there's a
specific item number 11 on here I'll ask
the monitoring officer to just say a few
words for the people that's relevant to
thank you Jay
um
item 11 is dealing with the community
governance review and I'm aware that
there are a number of uh deal Hatters in
in the council chamber and so I just
wanted to take this as an opportunity to
just clarify the whole thing about other
registerable interests so you've got
your disclosable peculiar interests but
this is your other registerable
interests so
other vegetable interests are those
bodies that you're either appointed to
by the council or other bodies of our
public nature Etc Parish Council so stay
Market freshfields Fresh and Fields
except Thursday and Etc
what's up that item in particular deals
with a membership of battle Ash freshen
field Parish Council Thurston Parish
Council one house Parish Council Stone
Market Parish town sorry still Market
town
Parish Council so for those members who
are on there that's this is really what
this is aimed at but also I just wanted
to make the general point about other
registerable interests because it
sometimes gets a little bit
um
but some other vegetable interests if
you've got one you clear it
if it affects the financial or
well-being of that organization
you are then entitled to speak if a
member of the public is entitled to
speak with the Forum you're in if the
member of the point out to speak you can
speak and then you must leave the room
and you
can see you declare
other branch
in respect of those three Parish
councils badwell Ash freshman fields and
Thurston
conclusion that
what's being discussed tonight is item
11 is just the numbers of councils
so it doesn't affect the well-being or
financial position of those councils and
therefore if you have
if you are a member of those councils as
well as a district councilor you don't
have to register you'd have to state
that you have a other vegetable interest
it's obviously already on your register
of interest but you don't need to
declare it tonight
feel free open some transparency and
we'll make a minute of it we'll make a
record of it
but you don't have to
with regards to one house Paris Council
Stone Market Town Council and
battersford Parish Council again item 11
the
purpose of item 11 is continue the
community governance review with respect
of those four authorities
so anyone who's a member of those again
you think well actually will it affect
the well-being or financial
position of those who thought it doesn't
because the decision is merely today is
to just
carry on a decision that was already
made previously to start Community
government's review carry that Community
governance review on that's what that's
what you decide so it doesn't affect the
well-being financial position
however
when the matter comes back once those
Parish once those parish and Town
Council boundaries once they've been
resolved and a recommendation is made
when that comes back those members
will have a but there will be a
financial interest because you're moving
the boundaries those are boundary
changes they will have an effect on the
financial position of those perishing
town councils so in those in that
circumstances you will have an other
registerable interest in
same what you need to say and then you
leave I just wanted to clarify it now
because it's one of those things that
crops up time and time again and this
was a really useful time to just sort of
for those of you who are members of
those other councils that I've just
mentioned you are entitled to take have
regard to the monitoring officer's
advice and my advice is that you don't
need to record record today as a as a
other vegetable interest my advice is
you don't need to leave and you can vote
you can take part
feel like you want to just register the
fact that you've got all these other
interests please do so and we'll
thank you very much is that
yes are these questions for clarity yeah
could we take those councilor Mathison
sorry counselor field you're next
thank you yeah so that only refers to
people who are members of the relevant
Parish councils not those that represent
them here at the district while not
being members of the parishes concerned
be it's a good sign and the and the
other the other point of information
really is that
um that which affects battersford will
affect Combs
the boundary change in the future
that's inevitably if you're moving the
boundaries it affects two people
thank you thank you for that I'll add
that to the list then that's Coombs
Parish Council to the list but uh in
terms of represent
only in relation to those bodies on
which you're on control and management
in a controlling management position so
it doesn't if you're representing that's
fine but if but not not only if you
actually sit on those councils
thank you Council field
thank you I'm sure I know the answer but
uh you missed by them which is a village
currently a parish meeting which is in
Paris Council and I live in that Village
I have taken some part in the
discussions that lead to the application
to be a parish council but but there
clearly isn't any Financial impact of
that as far as I'm aware of man
my assume I don't have to declare
anything but
please no you're quite correct because
it's a parish meeting
doesn't come under the definition
of another body
so so no but once it's a parish council
uh councilor Brewster are you are you
stretching your arm or are you trying to
get my attention
I am a member of still Market Town
Council and
um
could I take that declaration in a
moment I'll just speak to councilor
emiration about the clarification and
then I'll then I'll do the Declarations
all together thank you
councilor Emma Rosen thank you chair so
I'm just wondering um so the
the council's in question in the
left-hand column uh have to declare I'm
wondering if the adjoining
boundary areas
you know the other side of the boundary
that's uh that they're in question are
also effectively because arguably that's
that could still be like a Financial
[Music]
uh area so for example I'm in stone
market so I would
eventually have to declare
um but would like the one wanna house
cancer I also have to declare
monitoring officer
yes in the future but not today
foreign
everybody quite clear on that yeah
oh councilor Mueller
yeah no I would declare that obviously
I'm a member of Stone Market Town
Council and also a member of the
community government's review small
group of councilors involved with that
thank you
thank you very much um councilor
Brewster
uh Community governance review
thank you very much
councilor Humphries Mr chair thank you
also declare I'm a member of Stone
Market Town Council thank you
counselor
I too would like to declare that I'm on
the market Town Council chairman
right is that all the Declarations of
Interest
counselor Morrison I'm slightly confused
I thought I thought it was just said
that today we don't have to declare in
in my view I think
if you feel like declaring it doesn't do
any harm for that transparency
um the monitoring officers it's clearly
said it's not necessary in his view for
anyone to declare but as in the spirit
of transparency within the council
um I'm happy to take declarations if
people just want to want to do that I'm
also it's worth noting that if any point
in the meeting people feel like they
actually haven't declared an interest
um that that exact moment that you
realize in that meeting is the time
declare and please them as a as a point
of order please declare that interest so
we if if something if you miss something
and you suddenly realize I'm quite happy
to take them at any point but um yeah so
it's up to you you can declare or not
sure in that case yeah in the spirit of
transparency I am on Stone Market
tankers
yeah and they'll just have a comment
from the monitoring officer
to the puzzle really if you like is uh
dispensations so we've got a number of
counselors here who have declared an
interest absolutely fine
if we get to a point where someone makes
a request for a dispensation because
Community governance review is gonna
it's gonna come up in the future as well
so it may be worth its while to have a
dispensation so you so you're not
prevented from discussing so when Stone
Market and one house come back for
example you're not stopped from actually
taking part in the discussion and all
that requires is a request of the
monitoring officer in RIT
just thought I'd mention that now that's
councilor Manson
thank you moving away from Stone Market
do we not need a dispensation to discuss
the council tax reduction scheme it may
affect any one of us
the annual Council the last annual
Council for the next four-year period
but but anyone watching I I would like
to uh that to be open that we're doing
it again now it may have been that we
were granted a dispensation eight months
ago but people watching May well not
realize that
right okay um do you want to just
Clearly say that the dispensations have
been put in place for that please and
then we'll minute that if that's okay
it's happy to confirm that there is a
dispensation in place with regards to
the council tax reduction scheme
thank you very much and I don't think
there's any more Declarations of
Interest so we'll I'll move on to um
item three on the agenda
mc228 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of November
2022 for accuracy only are there any
issues with accuracy
I can't see any hands could have a
propose it for these minutes please
councilor Morley and a second to
councilor geek
thank you very much
um all that we'll do this by show of
hands um all in favor please
and that's carried thank you
so that takes us on to item four
mc229 Chairman's announcements I'll
refer you to paper
mc229 for noting but also um to let you
know that on the 21st of January I
attended stay Market ASD Saturday clubs
for um
to
um to take part in to draw for the grand
prize draw in there
um it was really good that's my chosen
charity for the year and I'm really
impressed with all the work they do
they're just opened a parents Cafe
um where parents can sit and um have a
chat and talk about um issues or or just
socialize while the children are looked
after by the um Saturday club which I
think is a really good addition and the
only other thing is on you'll all have
had an invitation
on Sunday the 5th of February I've got
my um Civic service at Brantford church
so um if you could attend that that
would be um absolutely wonderful thank
you very much
so um
I'll go on to item five which is leaders
announcements councilor Morley
[Music]
thank you Jay
since our last meeting
I'm pleased to say that Freeport East
has received final government approval
allowing it to move forward into the
delivery phase
the development of the Freeport which
includes Gateway 14 at Stone Market as
one of the three main development sites
is expected to create up to 13 and a
half thousand new jobs
getting to this major Milestone is an
important moment
and the result of much hard work
from a number of different organizations
including mid-suffolk District Council
the opportunities to welcome businesses
to the region as well as to create
employment for people in and around
stone market and the mid-suffolk area
will provide a huge boost to our local
economy
and I'm also pleased to report that this
afternoon I attended the groundbreaking
ceremony for the range
our new solar car ports have been
unveiled at mid-suffolk Leisure Center
in stone market and I was delighted to
see this pioneering project complete
70 solar car ports are located at the
center providing up to almost 24 percent
of the center's annual electricity
demand
we are among the UK's first rural local
authorities to trial the technology
which will not only reduce the center's
Reliance on the grid but also cut carbon
emissions
the site also includes battery storage
so excess energy produced during sunnier
periods can be saved for later
as well as electric vehicle charging
points
combined with a similar scheme at
Kingfisher Center in Sudbury
The Works cost 1.4 million pounds which
was funded by eight hundred thousand
pounds match funding from Deluxe getting
building fund awarded by the new Anglia
local Enterprise partnership
this was topped up by a combined 650 000
from the councils
it is a good example of the Innovative
work we are doing to reduce carbon
emissions
as you will be aware the government has
introduced a requirement for voters to
show photo ID when voting at a polling
station
the local and Parish elections in May
will be the first time that electors
will need to show voter ID
mid-suffolk District Council is
committed to ensuring residents are
fully aware of what is happening and we
will be using our full range of
communication channels to support the
Electoral commission's national campaign
within our district
members can also play a key role in
raising awareness of these changes and
there are resources available to help
all members have been sent details of
these changes to help you respond to any
questions this includes a summary of the
accepted forms of photo ID that can be
used in polling stations
it also shows how residents without any
of the accepted forms of photo ID can
apply for a free a free voter ID
document known as a voter Authority
certificate online or complete a paper
application form
more details are available on our
website or the Electoral commission
website
and finally our new Fleet of
environmentally friendly bin lorries has
now hit the road and I want to say thank
you to the hundreds of our residents who
suggested names for them
the two-week long competition saw over
400 individual individual name
suggestions from people of all ages this
was a great response
the council's crew and waste team chose
22 from the shortlist and came up with
an excellent list
so we warmly welcome Ed sheer Ben and
Gary biniker amongst others to their new
rounds
thank you chair
are there any
um councilor even
comments a solar carpool
250 000
pounds from the councils was that slip
of the tongue or was that
was that from it's Suffolk or was that
mid-suffican baby or was that if you can
just clarify that 650 000 please thank
you
I think the 600 sorry I've lost both
councils but of course both councils and
for the ones in that were done and
produced in mid-suffic as well as the
ones that are installed in baber thank
you
thank you I will I will check
thank you very much councilor Mathison
thank you yeah um we're all working
quite hard to help um make sure the
residents know about the the voter ID
um but whereabouts are the paper
applications to be obtained in the
districts
councilor Morley
a chief exec I'll provide the answer
outside the meeting just to double check
rather than give you an answer now maybe
wrong but essentially the Electoral
commission's website provides all the
details as to how to obtain it I
appreciate the question is about how do
I get a paper copy not an online version
so we'll provide that outside the
meeting
foreign
Matheson that's a good point I think and
um well um we'll hear from the chief
executive are there any other um
questions of clarity no thank you very
much
so um then item six to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with Council procedure rules
item seven questions by the public in
accordance with Council procedure rules
none received
item eight questions by councils in
accordance with Council procedure rules
none received chance thank you very much
so that moves us on to item nine which
is
mc2230 overview and scrutiny committee
report I'd like to invite councilor
wellum the chairman of avian scrutiny to
introduce his poor report please
thank you chair this report is a catch
up from October to December the report
is promoting I'm quite happy to attempt
to answer any questions from Members
thank you
thank you so um thank you we have a
question from councilor partner um thank
you very much chairman and thanks for
the report key just a quick one you may
want to come back later
um in the report it talks about
[Music]
um
how the councils facilitate the more
collaborative approach between
organizations something I'm sure we are
all very very supportive of I just
wondered what that might be what what
actions might be taking in order to
facilitate it because we've got so many
organizations working in quite a crowded
area
um and if you can't answer it now by me
send me an email later but I'm very
supportive of that approach of joining
things up and Suffolk thank you very
much
um
this is really something which the mem
the uh Cabinet member and the uh
officers recognize that there could be
improvements and I think that that's
something that they and the cabinet
member will be working on if not already
thank you
thank you very much another question
from councilor scarf and then Council
Pratt thank you thank you chairman um
page 21 and 20 refer to the review of
the local citizens advice and the cost
of living crisis and um
today I'm a member of our scribby
committee on page 21 Little B says that
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee supports the 30 uplift to
local citizens advice and the work being
conducted as a result we did
we did thoroughly approve of that extra
uplift app also recommends that this
support continues for a further two
years I wonder is the chair of the
security committee aware of where we've
got to on that particular subject
bearing in mind we're setting the budget
Council Willem
thank you thank you for the question
um yes uh there was unanimous support
from all members of overview and
scrutiny
so we should expect to see the 30 uplift
included in the budget for the next two
Financial years and we will no doubt see
that within the next few days thank you
very much councilor Pratt
thank you chair
um so my question is regarding the
review of the local citizens advice and
the cost of living crisis did that
review cover people who experience rural
poverty and lack access to transport to
Urban centers where much of that help
and assistance is provided
William
yes thank you for the question
um there was not a great deal of debate
around that but there weren't there were
um members of the committee mentioned
various aspects of
um Rural Life that are obviously
different from urban life uh and from
citizens advice
their point is that they deal with Urban
and uh rural residents so anybody who
comes to them they will deal with their
concerns
but I think it's um it's for the
district council to ensure that rural
residents are not disadvantaged in terms
of support that the district council
gives during this period of Crisis thank
you
thank you thank you a question from
councilor Davies
oh thank you chair uh this question uh
picks Upland something I think it comes
through a passport
as in December Salk gave us a
presentation the security committee and
during that they explained that both
West Suffolk and East Suffolk support
formally support sulk
um
so she also explained that at this
moment in time mid-suffic doesn't
formally support sulcus so my question
is really can we
support itself because it provides a
great deal of good service to our Parish
uh chairs as well as our Clarks so both
a formal uh
link with them and possibly preferably
some sort of financial support would be
I'm sure greatly appreciate it councilor
Willem
chair thank you thank you for the
question uh it it isn't really for
overview and security too to to tell the
um the administration how they should
support uh so
um clearly
so so we're asking for the support and I
trust that's something that will be
dealt with and again I guess that's
something which comes within the um
communities portfolio thank you thank
you councilman Mansell
uh thank you chair um I I'm referring uh
my question to section 3.2.2 on page 21
uh about the
um uh scrutiny cabinet protocol
um and I just like I'd like the uh
assurances of the scrutiny committee
that we all as councilors can be assured
that that this uh taking on board this
new protocol uh will uh improve the
working relationship between cabinet and
the overview scrutiny committee and I I
think this is great that we've got a
successful outcome from the corporate
peer review thank you
thank you chair thank you for the
question
um well I can assure you that the
overview of security committee welcomed
the uh the protocol and will do
everything they can to work closely with
cabinet
um there there was clearly a need for
such a protocol
um it was identified during the peer
review and we will just make have to try
to make sure that it does it does work
better in the future there have been
some improvements
[Music]
um
for instance a track a tracker now of
recommendations
um and also we're anticipating that the
meetings that the chairs hold with the
leaders will be more fruitful than they
have been in the past thank you thank
you very much councilor wellum and um
with that we'll move on to item 10.
um oh
um yeah the recommendations from cabinet
and committees and we would start with
10A MCA 2234 which is the council tax
reduction working age scheme 2023 to
I would like to invite now councilor
Whitehead to introduce this item and to
move the amended recommendations please
thank you chairman
um as a council we operate two powerful
tax production schemes one schemes for
those of state pension age and it's a
scheme prescribed by Statute and local
Council to prohibited on changing any
aspect of that scheme a second scheme
the one we're looking at to amend today
relates to those the working age where
government gives us some discretion in
its operations
proposed changes to our local Council
construction scheme for work age 2023 24
were first put before cabinet
back in October last year
the various options were carefully
considered and options three which is
clearly described in the reported in
front of us today was chosen as
cabinet's preferred option
however that was just the start of the
process that concludes today before
making any changes the castle has a duty
to consult on any proposed changes
under the regulations
it must consult with any major
precepting Authority that has the power
to issue a precept
it must publish the draft scheme which
clearly helps in the consultation and
also consults such persons as it
considers are likely to have an interest
in the operation of the scheme
and this latter includes not only
Council taxpayers where they presently
pay full or Park council tax but also
advisory and charitable bodies
so cabinet duly authorized that former
consultation process and it took place
over a six-week period in the late
autumn
and the results that consultation are
set out in detail appendix D of today's
report
honestly it's worth noting that only 28
centers responding actually benefit from
the present reduction scheme so over
two-thirds of all respondents are paying
council tax at full contribution
contribution rate
nearly four out of five respondents 79
supported a move to a maximum 100
reduction and an even higher percentage
91 percent
support the simplifying scheme and
reducing Administration costs
report then returned to Cabinet who
reviewed the responses to the
consultation
the arguments for simplification the
president cumbersome Administration
process when taking in conjunction with
the help
that have moved to a maximum 100
reduction will provide some of our most
strategically challenged residents
seems conclusive to me my cabinet
colleagues all agreed
but the final decision is one for full
Council to make
maybe we should also knows to include
the transitional protection scheme
funded from our covid-19 year mark
Reserve to ensure that we will simplify
the scheme so know when it's financially
worse off from its introduction
in addition to the proposed revised
scheme government in its provisional
settlement for 23-24 has created an
additional council tax support fund
which gives an award of up to 25 pound
where residual liability council tax
remains
this applies both to working age and to
pensioners
so in addition to the recommendation
coming to full Council that option three
be used as a basis to the working age
Council construction scheme in the
coming year
we have the further recommendations that
we dispute this council tax support fund
provided by central government
along with giving discretion to
determine how any residual money
remaining from this fund be distributed
now this is all set out in the
supplementary papers
I would hope the report itself clearly
sets out all the considerations and
reasons behind the choice options 3
along with the cost involved to the
various precepting authorities
but I appreciate this is a somewhat
complicated matter and therefore myself
supported by the relevant finance and
SRP officers present here today we'll be
happy to answer any questions that
members have
so I'd like to move chair the
recommendation is set out in these
supplementary papers and ask for a
second thank you
thank you chair Mr chairman I'd like to
secondhand reserve my right to speak
thank you very much we'll now move to
questions councilor eberne
foreign thank you councilor Whitehead
for your report
um I've got three questions if I may
um firstly for the for the avoidance of
Doubt could you just confirm exactly how
much
um the scheme is expected to to cost and
secondly
um with the government's
um council tax fund allocation that
they've just announced mid-suffer will
be receiving 114
116 pounds to potentially give this 25
pound
um up up to 25 pounds for vulnerable
households
um can you confirm whether that funding
will be used on top of the costs that
with suffolk's expecting to spend
and not
um the and the and not used
to fund this scheme that we're voting on
today
um
and just yeah so that whether we are
actually so whether that money from
government will be used
in addition to what we've agreed that
we're gonna we're gonna pay for if you
could just confirm that sum as well if
the influencer debt thank you very much
thank you
thank you um we've got councilor White's
head but we've also got the director
corporate resources the shared Revenue
partnership operations manager and the
corporate manager for finance
commissioning and procurement present so
um I'll I'll pass that over to you to
councilor Whitehead
thank you councilor you burn um the cost
of the cost scheme set out
on actually under option two which is
the safety has the same cost as option
three which shows
um the cost how it's spread out and
affects the County Council the police
and crime commissioner how it affects
mid-suffolk and the average cost and
overall parishes although Mississippi is
actually absorbing that and not passing
those costs on to the parishes so for
ourselves it's 16.6 million plus
subsidizing heritage the tune of 6.6
million
thousand yes
well you know what inflation's like
the police and crime commissioner 19.8
000 and County Council shops who have
the bigger bills anyway 114.5
000.
okay
um the the money that's come from the um
uh government for this 25 pound or up to
at least 25 pounds it's described
um my understanding is that will be
entirely used to distribute to those in
need but we I don't believe we've even
taken an admin charge out of at all and
I'll just get the offices to confirm
that but um so the back of the
distribution
I'm getting three nodding heads so
if that's clear
the answer was that we we will not be
using any part of that government money
to cover our own costs it will be given
out in its entirety
to the deserving residents
councilor even
thank you chair if I may come back on
that
um so you're saying that the total cost
is 16.6
um and the
of this scheme 16
600 pounds and so the 26 100 pounds
mentioned in option C
where does that fit in
um and
so and thank you for confirming that the
114 000 will be used in addition to that
what we're already paying thank you
councilor Whitehead
Mr I'm confused myself the uh because
we're because some people uh under this
simplify scheme could be losers as well
as many winners that there is this 26.1
000 pounds of participated cost I think
it averages about 168 pound per person
but we're taking that from our covid-19
Air Max Reserve
to follow that
so the the scene scheme is actually 42
700.
so the 16.6 plus the 26.1 but 16.6 we're
paying out of one pot and 26.1 we're
paying out of a covid pot that's so so
the actual if we weren't going to be
doing this scheme at all we wouldn't be
paying out forty two thousand seven
hundred
yes you've got it 99 there because we're
also we're also subsidizing the parish
dualistic about six million as well so
I've tried that onto your two figures
housed again
they're very generous to the parishes
councilor even Tim I'm sorry but I I'm
I'm really unhappy about this because I
think those figures should be right up
front in this report so I I would like
confirmation that the amount that we are
spending on this scheme because we
wouldn't know what we're voting on is
um 49 000.
at 49 000 and 300 pounds
which is the 16.6 from option two the
26.1 000 from
option three transition agreements and
the 6.6 that we're helping Parish
councils with so it's on my maths that's
um 49 300 pounds so I think we need to
be clear and that should have been up
front in the report but clear that that
is the total money is that correct
yeah councilor Whitehead would you like
to clarify I think there's another piece
of the jigsaw you're perhaps missing
within the report which suggests that
simplified Administration costs
certainly we are year one which
anticipated to save between 75 150 000
which is yeah yeah there's no such thing
as a free lunch yeah thank you
thank you I'm a councilman Mansell
uh thank you chair
um Council Whitehead did did uh direct
our attention to appendix D of the
report which was to do with the survey
results
um and uh he said as part of the
statutory requirement that we have to
consult And yet when we look at appendix
d uh it says 53 people were surveyed
which looks to me and and please if I'm
wrong please tell me I'm wrong that
looks rather pitiful number of uh people
who responded
um can you
um explain to me how the survey was
advertised distributed power people
encouraged to fill it in because was it
only sent to 53 people or was it a
broader thing than that I just like a
bit more detail on that and the other
um question I would like or maybe it's
more of a comment than a question is uh
we're talking here about simplifying our
scheme so that that's ease of
administration costs and I know we've
had a lot of conversation uh via Council
Ebon about the confusing nature of this
report but on it we are talking about
percentage reduction in people's council
tax payments and yet the the table that
I think is on page
um page 34 actually has some monetary
figures in
um and not percentages and it would be
much easier for us to compare like with
like but I would like some more details
on the survey
um how how we
are you are you disappointed with that
response or is that what you were
expecting and how would we encourage
people to do more participation in the
survey in future I think
councilor Whitehead thank you um yeah I
think
where it says brackets 53 people
surveyed I think that's Fitness I should
say basically that's 53 people responded
you know over above the um statutory
casualties
I think somewhere in the reported
explains the process in terms of the
mechanics of the consultation but if if
going through the brief briefly how it
works director of corporate resources
thank you chair and yeah we did a number
of social media
on the website as well so I'm posting
them to the website
um it was also in all of our benefit
notifications that we sent out as well
what sign Point putting them to them as
well as the council tax bills as well so
it was covered
thank you councilor
yes please come back
um thank you so um just to clarify uh
Council Whitehead said that was 53
people who responded over and above the
statutory consultees so there were more
than 53 responses and would you say are
you a bit disappointed that only 53
people responded given that you have
attempted to advertise it fairly broadly
or is that at what you expect
Council Whitehead the uh
I mean given how many residents we have
to 80 000 53 to see we're very sort of
sad number but you tend to find that the
more contentious something is the more
people respond so basically I think
givenly how
the efforts we put into doing this
um which I think has been explained
quite
um like varied that um I think it's fair
to draw a conclusion that if only 53
people responded that it's not not seen
as particularly contentious
councilor Pratt
okay yeah my question is based around
eligibility and who
um those who may or may not be eligible
um for the council tax reduction scheme
um so as I understand this is going to
be working off the back of universal
credits there may be individuals on
personal in Independence payments who
who have a recognized disability of
course may not be claiming Universal
credits will they be eligible for this
scheme what about those who do not
receive a personal Independence payment
but do have a recognized disability
would they be also eligible for the
scheme if the question is no to either
one or both of those
put some of that extra money coming from
the council tax support fund be used to
help these individuals thank you
for the Whitehead I shall refer that to
Eddie Mays who is our expert that's the
shared Revenue partnership operational
manager thank you thank you chair
um
to an existing
scheme that we have in operation at the
moment Works off the back of the old
housing benefit
means tested scheme and all people on
low incomes can apply and receive a
council tax reduction that scheme will
continue for those people who are on
those Legacy benefits who haven't yet
migrated onto Universal
team is offering a simplification to
people on Universal Credit if you work
you pay something if you don't work you
pay nothing but the main simplification
comes because Universal Credit
recalculates so often that people are
receiving bills on a monthly basis and
before they're able to make their first
installment their benefit recalculates
again so in answer to your question
anyone on a low income can apply anyone
on a low income will be eligible for
help under this scheme
thank you thank you and a question from
councilor Passmore
um thanks very much chairman I just
wonder whether I ought to declare an
interest actually because this does
affect the policing budget and as a
police and crime commissioner I'm afraid
I'll have to make that decision on my
own as opposed to a council making
decision is it all right if I continue
yes it's fine so one of the questions I
wanted to ask
uh if you have multiple incomes in a
house how does that affect it because
you could have I don't know um three or
four people living in there where the
income is relatively quite high as
opposed to the council tax being down as
I understand it to one individual is
that taken into account with this scheme
and how is it all balanced out I'm sure
it is but it's very complicated but just
some clarification would be helpful
please chairman
councilor Whitehead that's something
again I'd like to just um ask the
opposite of to clarify because obviously
with myself that we often seem to talk
about individuals on this whereas
obviously council tax is raised on on a
house and the household so okay again
fantastic Amy please shared revenues
partnership operational manager
picture
um so council tax is a household tax
council tax reduction is looks at the
household's income so if you are a
single person or you're a couple or you
have a family with adult children
um all of those elements are taken into
consideration now
um Universal and we do those assessments
we do the means tests that determines
people's eligibility if you're in
receipt of Universal Credit then the DWP
undertake that means test so they look
at the household income and they make a
determination as to eligibility based on
the household income again
thank you very much councilor Emma
rayson
real orthogonal point but just just uh
spotted something on that's in the
appendix C page 62
um table 6.2 and 6.3 which are both
different investment funds um
have uh the same annual performance
figures
sorry
I'll bring that up next oh you'll be
first when we get onto that yeah I'll
call you up first
thank you very much
thank you councilor
um now will a question from councilor
Stringer
oh sorry unlike me to be in the wrong
place
with the clarification on on what we're
actually about to vote on you did say
that the the 25 pound payments were
going to be extra and they were going to
be giving to
you said deserving residents how do we
determine who's deserving
is it those identified in the document
that might fall of this over carers and
those not on Pips or even those with
pips
councilor Whitehead
sorry perhaps my wording was perhaps a
little careless but again I
am Amy to to answer more particularly
just how this scheme which is it came
out pretty late I think just before
Christmas is part of the provisional
settlement just how this will actually
work which is why it's done some Venture
papers
thank you this is the shared Revenue
partnership operational manager thank
you
so pensioners and working age who have a
balance left to pay so if we move to 100
council tax scheme then there is nothing
to pay however for people who earn a
little more or who have other income
that means test will mean that they have
something to pay and certainly people
who work a neuron Universal Credit will
make a contribution so the 25 pounds
will apply to the balance that they have
remaining or up to whatever the balance
is
thank you very much councilor Carter
yes thank you
um just to clarify sorry if we got
myself confused
um I understand that those who are still
still can apply if they're on pip and
not on Universal Credit
um but we're talking about as well a up
to 100 reduction which is named by
cancer tax reduction names on universal
credits will be hunts and production
also apply to those applying for this
scheme or is it only for those on
universal credits this doesn't make it
clear in these notes Here
cancel the Whitehead
it's both but I'm just say if I should
just
not his head which means yes it's
okay thank you very much so um that's
the end of the question so um we'll now
move on to the debate
part of this
um councils would be allowed to speak
once and for no more than three minutes
would anybody like to start the debate
councilor eburn
um thank you very much chair um firstly
I just want to say that I will be
supporting
um this recommendation I think anything
that we can do
um both to um make life easier in terms
of administration of schemes like this
for for offices
um but and also for residents but also
to ease that um the burden on the most
vulnerable residence I think even if
you're getting a bill per se and you
don't know what it's going to be per
month even if it's going to be a few
pounds and you're desperately trying to
budget
um it's it's very difficult so anything
we can do to help that I really welcome
I am concerned that there's that we've
had to work through what are the actual
costs of this and that hasn't been very
clear in the papers and I think I'd like
to see that addressed better in the in
the future and even when um you know
councilor Whitehead reminded me of the
cost savings with the the total spend
will be forty seven thousand three
hundred from different pots at
mid-suffolk but the savings it says
potential future savings 75 000 to 100
000 but that's across mid-suffolk and
baber and Ipswich so because that's the
SRP that's what it says in the in the um
report so
you know we still don't know and I think
I I would if this was just saying we
were going to spend 47 000 let me make
it clear I would say let's spend the 47
000. but it'd be you know it would be
good to know what the actual amount of
of savings would be for mid-suffolk
rather than for
um the overall group of councils
um thank you chairman
thank you very much would anyone like to
continue councilor Passmore yeah yeah
thank you chairman um yeah I'm going to
support this scheme um but I do want to
make the point that of course it does
have implications for other authorities
I'm not just talking about police and
crime commissioner but the figures there
that we've seen for County councils and
if one were to be critical I do think
this is sort of thing as I say I'm fully
supportive of this that is where I think
central government funding actually
ought to come in to help compensate
other organizations as well because it
does have an effect on others budgets
you know we're talking bit Parish
Council some of us we've got a much
higher preset than others and town
councils and so on so this is not
something to go into lightly but I think
with the current situation we're in and
having had the clarification regarding
total household income that's fine the
other thing I would just like to mention
I do think these schemes are fine
one of the problems you potentially have
is those people who don't just quite
qualify for this and they just over the
edge on there there is a strong message
we need to be able to have there ready
for what we're doing because when you
have a Line in the Sand
and you're on one side okay that helps
you could be just over it and that has
always been one of the challenges I
think for welfare payments benefits of
which clearly this is one of men were
speaking and encouraging people to go
back to work or work and so on and then
Heaven Only Knows we've got such star
shorties everywhere now we're not going
to sort that tonight but I just wanted
to make that clear I am supporting it
but it does have perhaps some unintended
consequences that we all regardless of
politics need to be aware of and be able
to answer questions should they come up
at Parish councils or whatever thank you
thank you very much and um councilman
yeah I I just wanted to um
Sue um councilor e Bernie is quite right
about the clarity can we ask that the
um Communications Department get a press
release together the week
clearly sets out
what's happening here because I fear
that anybody watching the the YouTube
now or later will will um will be
scratching their heads somewhat
um so I think we can actually get that
sorted out and written down reasonably
quickly before anybody in the Press
tries to make a mess of it frankly
thank you councilor Mathison councilor
melon
yeah thank you chair I mean I think now
that we've sort of understood exactly
what's happening here I think um you
know it's clearly an eminently sensible
tidying up of
the procedure which benefits our staff
in terms of making their life easier and
and reducing the amount of
administration it benefits the
beneficiaries as it were and I'm
certainly going to be supporting it
thank you chair
thank you very much
um I can't see oh councilor Morley
[Music]
I I also will be supporting this I think
this is a really
timely intervention by our shared
revenues partnership team and will help
those of our
most vulnerable financially sorry
financially vulnerable residents for
those as councilor Passmore mentioned
who are the just about managing tribe we
also have our cost of living
strategy which was published just before
Christmas and that does go a long way to
supporting those those people who
perhaps just miss out on this particular
scheme
um and the other thing is whilst I don't
certainly don't agree that mid-suffolk
should do anything just because another
Council has done so both baber has
approved this and dips which have
approved this
and if mid-suffet do not approve this
then we will be carrying the overheads
for the implementation to carry on as it
is
so not only are we saving our residence
money
by proving this we are saving ourselves
so I have every intention of supporting
this
is very much councilor Pratt
thank you all to try and be brief yeah
um I wholeheartedly support this too for
the reasons that have been expressed I
think it will really help some of our
most vulnerable residents and households
especially when things are financially
quite difficult at the moment I do also
hold concerns that there may be some
vulnerable people who don't quite get
caught in in the in this sort of net as
it is like as we've mentioned before
these
personal Independence payments are not
necessarily means tested on income as
far as I understand so I'm not entirely
sure whether everyone who's eligible for
pip will be eligible for this but would
be like benefiting from it so it's those
as you say are just on the edge
and maybe this is not really um a viable
idea but maybe there could be some sort
of facility for those who are on pip or
have other extenuating circumstances
could self-refer to be included in in
the scheme or something
um but yeah I will definitely be
supporting this
thank you councilor wellum
thank you chair I'll be supporting it as
well but my concern is around what
happens at the end of the year this is
this is a one year only are we going to
make sure that we're monitoring it and
the office has come forward earlier in
the next uh the next financial year so
that um
we know what's going to follow on at the
end of this year thank you
thank you very much
councilor ekron young did you want to
speak
yeah would you like to speak now if
you're going to thank you
this is the second year of this proposal
I I will definitely be supporting it I'm
also pleased to hear from councilor
Morley with regards to the point that
councilor Passmore raised that you know
we have another safety net for those
that are kind of borderline with regards
to this particular
um and and it you know it's our duty as
a council to try to support all of our
residents that have difficulties with
money as much as possible with the funds
that are at our disposal so I would
highly recommend this uh proposal to the
council to support
thank you very much
would you like to add anything councilor
White's head
let's just say I'm glad to hear it seems
to have support across across the
council
um I think I'm fairly pleased that in my
introductory speech I did say that it is
uh somewhat complicated matter
um but and I do feel that um within the
papers it did set out quite clearly
um you know the cost of the individual
precepting authorities perhaps we've got
to be more clear in terms of the fact
that we were surprisingly surprising the
parishes but the Figures were in there
and the tradition the transitional
protection scheme and the cost of that
you know was clearly shown as a separate
cost and
um but um overall you know in terms of
Christmas we've liked the report we'll
take those on board officers are here
and I've heard them in terms of any
future clarification of the future
reports but um yeah I hope it can get
Universal support this thank you
thank you very much and we'll um take
that to the um vote now
I will now ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for cancers to cast their vote
Council Fleming can I take your vote
please
yes thank you um four please thank you
that's 33 4 so that's unanimous soon
carried
you very much
we'll now go on to item 10B Jac 2138
half a year report on Treasury
management 2022-2023
I would like to invite councilor Muller
to introduce this item and to move the
recommendations on the agenda please
councilor Muller
chair
this is the joint treasury management
report covering the position for the
first six months of the financial year
it provides details of performance the
effects of decisions taken during that
period and compliance with the council's
treasury management policy
the report explains the factors
affecting the strategy and activities
including the regulatory framework
economic conditions interest rate and
liquidity risk the economic backdrop
during the April to September period
continue to be characterized by high oil
gas and commodity prices ongoing High
inflation and an impact on consumers
cost of living no imminent end in sight
to the Russia Ukraine hostilities and
its Associated impact on the supply
chain and China's zero covered policy
interest rates have climbed with the
bank rate increasing from 0.75 in March
to 2.25 by the end of September the bank
of England increased it further to 3
percent in November with the majority of
the committee judging that further
increases may still be required
so more specifically for our Council One
banking activities undertaken were
within the daily bank account limits to
mid-suffolk has reduced its debt by 7
million three all investment activities
undertaken were in accordance with the
approved counterparty list four the
council's investment activities
including average returns can be found
at appendix C of the report five the
councils pulled funds excluding the ccla
have experienced a drop in valuation but
an increase in the rate of return
compared to
2122 and six the council is compliant
with the upper limits for interest rate
exposure the investment activity
undertaken for the first half year was
done so in priority order of security
and liquidity over yield as prescribed
in the treasury management strategy
however there is an error in the report
that I would like to make you aware of
paragraph 4.7 States Miss
42 yeah paragraph 4.7 thanks mid
suffolk's overall debt increased by 8.5
million this should read Miss suffolk's
overall debt decreased by 7 million in
line with table 3 and appendix B
and secondly table two in appendix a
which shows an increase of 8.5 million
is incorrect this should show medium so
long-term borrowing of
104.835 million and short-term borrowing
of 30.5 million at 31 322 and medium
long-term borrowing of
99.285 million and short-term borrowing
of 29 million at
30.922 I'm happy to take any questions
from membership report and I'd like to
move the recommendations shown in the
papers with ask the chair for a second
uh councilman Miller would you like to
just go through the two amendments yes
please again for counselors
page numbers if you'd like to take a
second to um get page numbers I'm quite
happy for you to do that
I'll read them again
um yeah there is an error in the report
that I would like to make you aware of
paragraph 4.7 States Miss suffolk's
overall debt increased by 8.5 million
this should read mid-suffic's overall
debt decreased by 7 million in line with
cable 3 and appendix B
table two in appendix a which shows an
increase of 8.5 million is incorrect
this should show Media stroke long-term
borrowing of 104.835 million and
short-term borrowing of 30.5 million at
31 322 and medium so long-term borrowing
of
99.285 million and short-term borrowing
of 29 million at 39.22
thank you chair and I'd ask for a second
councilor Manson just as a point of
order I really am struggling to work out
where these numbers what page I should
be looking at
um what what exactly needs to be changed
it would have been so much easier if we
could just have it had this on a late
paper or something because I really
can't take it all in I'm sorry
just as a point of order
would you like further clarification at
this point just being read out to me is
doing nothing for me I'm afraid I need
to I would like to see where the errors
are on a document uh whether it's on an
electronic documents fine but I just
think this is let last minute changes
um councilor Muller is is reading out
what he's got to read and I'm lost I'm
sorry
councilor geek
thank you chair could I make a
suggestion that we just have it once
more but slowly so that we can we the
second one the first one I think most of
us have got because we know it's on page
43. if you read out the number that is
in the document then we can
we can find it and you'd give a little
pause and then we when we found it you
can tell us what it should be and maybe
we can write it down it's just that when
you say 104 872 million and then on
table two and you know it's very hard
slow but great thank you
um
okay um we'll just go to the um
corporate manager to finance
commissioning and procurement for
clarification but um we do need to get
this exactly right to do this so um it
may take time but we want to make sure
everyone's got exactly the right figures
in front of them
apologies that this error has
so table two on page 53 has the
incorrect borrowing figures in it so it
has
um the incorrect figures table three in
on page 55 also has borrowing figures
and that has the correct borrowing
figures that show that the movement has
gone down by seven million
okay can you um tell us exactly what
numbers are changing and to what on each
on each page sorry but we we must get
this exactly right it's got to be 100 I
don't think yeah no problem so the
um table
three
and the figure of
97.335 medium long-term borrowing and it
should be 104.835
the short-term borrowing figure in take
Story table 2 on page 53
um in the report says 29 million and
this should be 30.5 million
and
the figure for the 30th of September
2022 medium long-term borrowing is
currently
104.285 in the report this should be 29
99.285
and also table two short-term borrowing
at 30th of September it's currently in
the report says 30.5 million and this
should be 29 million
right okay is everybody happy now
so we we're waiting for a second on this
um I'm a member of the audit committee
and I'm happy to Second it unless
somebody else would like to cancel the
Matheson
processes but I feel as if
so
um we must second it
will second it and and then we'll go
into questions
um
Council War boys is that a um
I'll just I'll just go through a bit of
process I'm happy to Second this and
then
um so um it's then moved on to um
questions and now please
start with your question we just needed
to make sure that yeah it was relative
to page 42 I think if I just find it
back
and we talk about the economic
background or the context in which
um this report is prepared
um and it's a little bit of a Grumble
really because we're looking at this
sort of six months on so we're well
behind the news cycle so I did have to
check to see what I was referring to was
was relevant at the time or have been
published at the time
and really
um the content the question about the
context is this we mentioned the the
ongoing war in Ukraine uh we mentioned
they're right the cost of energy and
commodity prices but I do feel we need
to also mention the context of barriers
to trade in particular trade with the
European Union which represent a
headwind against which the British
economy is struggling
um and the context of this is the in
March 22 the office of budget
responsibility
and talking about the context of trade
with EU
and the impact on the British economy
was saying the UK has a less trade
intensive economy the trade is falling
as a share of GDP falling 20 percent
since 2019. councilor War boys I must
push you for a question the question is
why is that not included barriers to
trade in particular with the Eurozone as
the context in which this report is
produced it does have a huge impact in
particular on our investments of time
and energy in the in the free ports
which are trade dependents
thank you um
can I get an answer the director
corporate resources
Council boys raised um but the economic
context is provided to us by our
treasury advisors all in close so
obviously they pick out the keybeats
that are relevant they think are
relevant to our investment so I can
certainly take that away and ask
if that is an impact for us and whether
we want to bring that back in further
reports going forward absolutely
yes please I'll be grateful for that
thank you thank you very much um Council
rotten
thank you chairman um I'd just like to
query on Page Six
who
um it's paragraphs well it's kind of 114
through to 117.
um where it states the international
financial reporting standards for pooled
fund status
etc etc and then goes on to say the
department for the left leveling up
housing communities undertook a
consultation on the state of the
statutory override and then goes on to
say that decision is yet to be announced
and I think it's important that we
understand what is happening here it's
when I see statements like unusable
reserves that it would be important to
know whether there are
possible changes in how councils are
able to manage thank you
corporate manager Finance procurement
and commissioning
thank you Jen thank you for your
question
um since this report report was written
we have actually had an announcement on
on this issue
um
what it is it's an accounting adjustment
that means that are the impact of Rises
or falls in the value of these
Investments don't impact on our Revenue
budget
that was due to end at the end of 22-23
the department has now confirmed that
that will be extended for a further two
years for 23 24 and 24 25 so it's it's
an amendment that means that following
the IFRS accounting requirements does
not have an impact on the council's
revenue budget
thank you very much councilor e Byrne
and then councilor emiration
thank you very much chair um I've got
um two questions for a man I just say
that I've I'm I'm on the joint audience
standards committee and have raised
these there
um
on the page 44 paragraphs 11.1 and 11.3
particularly 11.3 we're referring to
um the cabinet pushing fund managers to
filter investments in respect of
ESG considerations
and
what I would like to know is is what
work is happening by the cabinet to
progress that and then particularly
obviously
also in relation to 11.1 with all
Council activities needing to be
reviewed and what work is is happening
there to review those
my second question
um is on page 68
um the table
um
all that most of the tables where we're
talking about what investments we have
state the amount that was invested and
then what has been the change on
investment and so forth and the one that
doesn't is the one that refers to what
was our investment in Gateway 14 etc etc
so um I did ask in the meeting and I
just want to have it reconfirmed here
that future reports will show the
initial investment for sifco for Gateway
14 and for mid-suffolk growth so that
you can see that across time in the same
way you can see any other Investments
that mid-suffolk has thank you chair
thank you very much
is there any um
anyone wants to take that question
they're direct to corporate resources
thank you thank you
I haven't been in any
since I've been in my new role but it is
one that I will now have conversations
with them about going forward
uh yes we will take that board
absolutely yes sorry yeah
councilor Emma Rosen
apologies for jumping the gun early I
got my appendices mixed up
um
I just wanted to point it ask if there
is a potential error on page 64 in the
um Schroeder and UBS
tables the annual performance looks as
though it might be uh it's exactly the
same and that seems it seems uh unlikely
but
could be just a fluke
corporate manager Finance commissioning
and procurement I think chair thank you
for your question um Jessica I
understand that you're talking about the
difference between the the baber green
table and the the red mid-suffolk table
being the same no it's the it's the
Schroeder versus the UBS so uh table 6.2
and table 6.3 the annual performance
the balance
is
0.103 in both tables and the
uh so the so the net interest received
per year sorry is 103. 0.103 and the
average rate of return for a year is
5.61 and it's the same across two
different uh
Investments so it just seems unlikely
but I don't know it could be an anomaly
with me but I will check those for you
cheers
okay
um
councilor Mathison yeah yes a chair yeah
I I have a question and this relates on
page 60.
um and I wanted to ask um this will
probably need to go back to the director
again
um the the with frequently when we ask
the questions about
um ESG filtering and so on and so forth
we're frequently
um given the answer which essentially is
written down on Page Six in paragraph
1.6
um and I'm just wondering has this set
for code and the government guidance on
Treasury
um
still not
begun to to you know
recommend that we take into
consideration ESG criteria as as well as
the security and liquidity which we are
and Prudence which we are are frequently
urged to do
direct to corporate resource
sorry thank you forgot ahead of myself
there
um we're not aware of any conversations
happening with sifa at the moment
um my colleague to the left is actually
taking up a post receipt for
um in April so actually I might I might
give her a nudge to uh to have a
conversation with them and it certainly
is something we discuss across Suffolk
as well and because we've all got
Investments similar to this as well
um so it certainly use conversations
we're having across Suffolk but those
very little
Investments out there that will give us
the return that we're getting at the
moment but it's certainly something I
think we do need to push but it's
we have to push and balancing that with
the level of return we're getting so I
think we there is more work that needs
to happen around that absolutely
thank you councilor Mansell
off um of um
four at section 11.1
um it says all Council activities will
need to be reviewed as part of the work
as a climate change task group and have
regarded the council's ambition I was
under the impression that the climate
change task group was a task and Finnish
group and had finished and was no longer
meeting so if this statement looks to me
like it's in the future I'm just
wondering how that is actually happening
or whether that sentence needs to be
corrected and should say has been maybe
because I or is there another climate
change task group that's about to be set
up thank you
thank you director corporate resources
I've just had it confirmed that the task
group is no longer happening but that
doesn't mean that we won't continue to
feed into the work of the climate change
and make sure that we review this
activity through whatever guys we need
to going forward through that climate
change agenda
okay thank you for your questions and
we'll now move to debate would anyone
like to um start the debate
counselor I won't I won't speak longer
than what I've got to say tonight um no
I'm going to certainly support this but
I just wanted to make a couple of points
um I can remember many years one or two
others will remember here I know Andrew
certainly was here with Penny and Mike
and one or two others
there were problems with Investments of
public sector money going about I don't
know maybe 15 16 years you remember the
Icelandic Bank egg and all these sorts
of things and some Council got the real
difficulty many years ago because I
would say they were rather too gung-ho
and thought we'd get great big returns
and I've always believed that what we
have to do with any Investments bearing
mine is taxpayers money is go for good
returns as good as we can but really
look at the risk involved
so that we don't overdo it because it's
not ours to speculate within a reckless
way so I think the way this has done
this is very good you can always find
different interest rates Etc and of
course one would expect for the next six
months that we're well into now the
returns are going to be significantly
better because interest rates have come
back despite the pain to a more
realistic level how inflation war in
Ukraine and all these other things pans
out I don't know and I just wanted to
make one comment regarding what you
might call not so much ethical
investment we've got to be very careful
what do you mean by that but also
looking in other funds and so on
um if you look at how we support various
other economies which I think are pretty
unsavory nothing against the Chinese
people but the regime that runs China
with their disregard for human rights
and the environment Etc how do we put
that all into the mix all I'm saying
here everybody is it's pretty
complicated to get the balance right you
have to make a judgment
and my own view is you need to spread
the Investments so you get a reasonable
return which I think is what has been
done here there will always be nuances
but I do think a pretty good job was
being done there I know there's lots of
questions there's a lot to absorb here
but I shall certainly be supporting this
because I think the balance is right but
all of us of course have a
responsibility and an opportunity to
feed in views and then it's up to um
others to try and take them into account
but I think it's a hellishly difficult
balance to get spot on so we need to
look at this sensibly risk free as far
as you can and then a mixture we all
know with any Investment Portfolio
diversity frankly is a pretty good thing
to do so um just wanted to make those
comments chairman but I shall certainly
be waiting for this no problem
thank you councilor Passmore councilor
field
The Limited couple of things to say
really
I mean the first thing is my
choir that we have a report before us
a six monthly report so it's taken about
four months to get here
it's been toward it
it has quite a number of errors in it
yeah and this is not the first time it's
been published it's been told it before
I think it's fairly poor that we're
sitting here after that sort of delay
looking at a document was inaccurate and
which we've been having to scribble down
various numbers to give ourselves a
The View we should have
really
is just not good enough in my view so
that's the complaint about the the
process
um
it clears in document we haven't been
breaking any rules any of those sort of
things that one would choose to vote
against
but the second set of concerns perhaps
are around our investment funds I know
the ccla at the time this report was
produced actually the fund was worth
more than we invested and the interest
return is quite good
I did see a report from them a couple of
days ago which says by now they may be
doing less well but still above water
but all our other funds are have lots of
issuing Capital value that the
interest is essentially
consumed there's very little left
and I understand that there's been
changes in the accounting rules so that
loss in value won't appear on our books
so okay that's um
or want to play for another couple of
years so it's perhaps not a thing that
one should Panic about but it clearly
raises a question to me that although
Council passports right in uh obviously
in a matter of getting diversity that we
don't seem to have much diversity here
all everything's going in the same
direction
and one last question what we're doing
with this investment we're clearly
hope always the claim is that we're
making money which if you like
supplements council tax and pays for our
services but here we seem to believe to
an extent losing money which will not
see what we want thank you
thank you councilor field
and I don't see any fur oh councilor
epignon
thank you Mr German
um I have some sympathy with councilor
feels viewpoint but
um with any investment you know they can
go up and they can go down
and this is a snapshot at a point in
time so at this particular snapshot that
are all going down but I don't think
that should invalidate the investment
approach I think what we should be
thinking about is actually uh some
periodic review that looks at the
elements of of the Investments that we
have do they meet the risk profile that
we want are they as Diversified as they
should be and do they pick up on on ESG
and so on and let's be clear not all ESG
funds are doing particularly well in
fact in the last report I saw they were
all doing pretty badly so you know let's
just spare that in mind too so I think
you know despite the errors that we find
in the report and I would definitely
commend the officers to be much more
rigorous and the audit committee I think
have failed us I think in this regard so
they need to up the game as well I think
you know we should support this report
and and move forward on that basis thank
you
thank you very much councilor Pratt
yeah just a very quick comment um so
well I don't really have much of a view
as to whether investment portfolios are
the way forward or not but if they
indeed are then I would welcome closer
scrutiny of what we are investing our
funds in and um
perhaps uh we should be funding in
things that we want to see in terms of
change within our community things that
are good for the environment and perhaps
divest away from activities which are
not so good
thank you very much and um so this
particular
um report
um as a requirement of the code of
practice on Treasury management
we need to formally note this in full
Council so um I'd like to we this will
go to an electronic vote
um I will ask the corporate manager
governance and Civic office to conduct
the electronic vote now thank you
thank you chair that is showing in blue
for cancers to cast their vote
Fleming can I take your vote please
um yes four please thank you
councilor Guthrie are you having
technical issues can I can I take your
it's confirmed thank you
chair that is 30 votes for two against
and one abstention
it's carried
so this meeting's been going an hour and
a half
do you want to um push on with the
meeting or do we want a five minute come
for break
yeah everyone's everyone's happy to
carry on
okay thank you very much so we'll go on
to item 11
mc2231 Community governance reviews
2022.
an updated report has been um tabled and
I'd like to invite the monitoring
officer to introduce that report thank
you
thank you Joe
so the report is in the supplemental
papers mainly because I I made a change
to the the recommendations
so the initial recommendation on the
report was to conduct a further
Community governance review following
the county courts County council
elections in 2025. statutory guidance as
that any Community governance review
should be completed within a 12-month
period
the working group was set up in March
2022 so it's meant to be completed by
March 2023.
it clearly isn't going to be completed
within that time frame and the reason
for that is
as we move forward
is required there is a requirement to
have adequate and reasonable
consultation
the local government
boundary commission for England
have already conducted reviews of The
Electoral margin of electoral boundaries
and wall boundaries and district county
boundaries in
2018-19 and 2021 on the back of those
reviews
orders in place some of those orders
don't actually come into come to
fruition until 2027.
the issue here is you can't if you
haven't done adequate consultation
the boundary commission will not give
you consent so even if you go through
the whole of this review
you change the change the boundary you
then go to the boundary commission for a
consent and they say if you haven't done
any quick consultation you're not going
to get it that's the reason why I made
the amendment to the recommendation
because otherwise the recommendation was
saying those Community governments
reviews with regards to stowmarket Town
Council and um stock market Town Council
and one house
and Battleford Parish Council and cool
so I couldn't Parish Council those would
be conducted in 2025 well that's World
beyond the 12-month period
I couldn't
agree to that as monetary officer so
that that's why the chain that's why the
change is there
um we do we do look as though we're
going to go beyond the 12-month period
regardless
I've already been asked
multiplications of that the league
implications of that are potential
judicial review
of the councils
uh not doing it within the 12-month
period however my view is that any
judicial review will be limited
and that's just legal speak for being
able to say
because we're still continuing the
review
and equal in my view would allow us to
just continue the process that we are
still pursuing now the timetable
we're conducting a review on Battlefield
onehouse State Market Town Council and
one house
what are your requirements
now whether they once they come back
with what their requirements are as to
adequate consultation
then that will be put to the working
group which is still still in place and
then we can work
at how long it's going to take to
complete the reviews
because we need to be realistic whatever
their requirements are we need to make
sure that we carry out adequate
consultation with regards to that
um
no further unless anyone has any
questions okay thank you well before we
go to questions
um could I have a proposer
for the reckon councilor Richardson and
their seconder
councilor Whitehead and we'll now go to
questions and questions will be directed
at the monitoring officer not the
proposer and the seconder does anybody
have any questions counselor Orton and
then Pratt
a Friday isn't
going to have to make a statement now in
that I am disappointed there will be
debate for the um yeah I realize that
but if the question is why as part of
the community governance review why we
are now being presented with the
recommendation
the community governance review was not
tasked
to provide a boundary review we were
just there to look at the community
governance requests by the relevant
Parish councils so I would want to know
why we are now being asked to complete a
review which is unable to communicate a
review which is ongoing
foreign
office so it's important to note that he
wasn't actually in post
when this went to happened previously
but I will let you um
fortunately the implications are that
they are
the boundaries that
certainly The Stone Market submission
one hour submission and the battleship
submission
thank you councilor Pratt
chair
um so I am the ward member for
battersford um but as far as I
understand I don't have any other
registerable
um interests to to declare and making
these questions and so on that's great
um so battersford Parish Council as it
stated in the report has asked for
changes to its boundaries to incorporate
new developments that include um Bowl
corner and outlying properties as well
so the report states that there wasn't
sufficient time to carry out the level
of public consultation that was required
by the boundary Commission
uh within the time scales of this review
um
I believe or the best of my knowledge
Battlefield Parish Council requested the
boundary review
um
the time that I was elected as counselor
so we're talking some years ago now
um
so um it's been active for a very very
long time what I want to know is why um
was adequate consultation not
carried out within this time frame and
if possible maybe a question for clarity
how much more time is required for a
decision even if we can sort of give a
ballpark
um thank you
thank you the monitoring officer
um
unfortunately I'm unable to comment as
to why it wasn't conducted within within
the time point that it should have been
um in regards to giving a a time scale
moving forward as I said the only way I
can give you a time frame is that we go
back to the commission
ask the commission what their
requirements are so that this doesn't
end up being a frequency exercise I we
get a once the review comes to a
conclusion then we get a proper well we
get consent I think
apologies I can't comment any further
thank you and and just to know the um
the answer to any questions that involve
historic actions on this will be a very
similar answer to um that so if we could
um
because obviously the the monitoring
officer wasn't imposed at that time to
find it hard to comment can I just
yeah a good place
I'll check what's up with your
say is that the
initiative wide so the initial questions
as well as I can see just went out to
the parish councils I went out to the
town councils it didn't appear to go any
further
there were sponsors that came back those
the
um 12 or so responses those are the
subjects of not just the mid-suffolk
boundary review but also the baber
boundary B so
those those then become the framework
for moving forward so those are the
submissions those are the only ones who
have made the requests for what they've
requested so the band review then
concentrates on those
that
but initially it was District wide so
190 odd Parish Council parish and town
councils were requested and then it
narrows it down
the in my view
um it doesn't appear to have been that
level of concept the next level of
consultation then is well what about the
residents what about the housing
associations for those other
stakeholders who live in the area
the boundary commission are quite clear
that it's actually at the council's
discretion as to what our level of
consultation is
but that gives you the next problem
which is if you
I believe at the moment it's not
adequate
but if we were just to go straight off
to the boundary commission
would they want more and so the answer
really is we've got to do it properly we
should go back and plus there are more
stakeholders that should be consulted
and in my legal view as well as my
thank you very much councilor Davies
you'd hear just a small um
point
for Thurston
I believe we have
2939 electors
rather than 1185.
so point of correction
thank you chair
uh
and that point was clarified before the
meeting and in the papers that are
updated on the website they do include
the correct number of electors for
Thursday it has been updated in
modern.gov uh on obviously in our pack
but it is in the website as the correct
figure okay thank you for that
clarification
um councilor scarf
picture
um
this whole paper gives me some concerns
I've got two questions and I don't know
where the monitoring officer will be
able to answer them well my first
question is what lessons will we as a
council learn from this community
governance review because clearly things
have gone very wrong
second question is was the working group
given the right brief I was the working
group given the right information by
officers of this Council in order to
come to a conclusion
thank you
the monitoring officer
my apologies I'm not able to comment
neither of those two questions
would you like to come back councilor
staff
if I came come back chair I I honestly
think that there are issues that we need
to address as a council following this
review which hasn't actually produced
the result Within 12-month period And I
think it is a shame that tonight we
don't get an answer to some of those
questions there are other officers of
this Council who have been part of the
review process
and not present tonight therefore we
don't get an answer I think if we could
have an answer to those questions by
those officers at a later date but to
all members I think we'd be better a
better place to know what exactly has
gone wrong
thank you
um councilor Mansell
uh thank you um I too have been a member
of the working group on community
governance for some time and actually
what
Mr Ali has said today has actually
clarified something that I was a little
bit confused about regarding battersford
um because I was first made aware of
battersford back in 2019 or 2020 and
then covid happened and then all of a
sudden there was a new boundary review
which was this district-wide one that I
believe is what we're now talking about
but my question is that the boundaries
that are in question
I believe are Ward boundaries as well as
Parish boundaries and does that have any
sort of deeper
consultation or process required for it
rather than just a parish boundary
within one of our own wards
Thanking us to the monitoring officer
so
I've seen clarification from the
boundary commission but
certainly more consultation than what's
happened to date because it will be
affecting I mean I I was not even aware
of parents Council they certainly
didn't put forward a submission but they
will be affected so therefore they
obviously need to be consulted
okay
um the the original as a point of order
the original report in in March 2022
which came here was Edward McCready who
is still who was imposed then and didn't
post now so perhaps it would have been
helpful to have him here at this meeting
tonight and that original report was was
also from the leader of the council so
maybe some of the questions about
um whether this has been done
effectively or not could be it could be
addressed by the leader thank you chair
okay thank you
um councilor epignon
new Council want to pose questions which
um our current uh monitoring officer is
unable to address because he wasn't
around uh but we had a long-standing
monitoring officer prior to his arrival
and uh
and there are other offices that are
still around and I think actually we
should be asking the chief executive to
make comment upon this situation because
he was clearly here during the whole
period and and he was under his watch
and something has not been done properly
or carefully
um and and putting our citizens out of
joint as it were so to speak and I think
not only must we have a comment from the
chief executive about what has gone I
think we need a clarity about the
program going forward and I don't think
actually the information the answer from
the marketing officer is really
sufficient
do as this is not questions for the
chief executive I'll ask him if he would
care to answer this I'm more than happy
to Chairman thank you for cancer Epping
on for passing that one to me
um
happy to acknowledge that clearly this
hasn't been done in the way that we've
been expected to be done in the way that
you would all expected to be done also
happy to to note the fact that this is
messy This is complicated this is not
straightforward in terms of the process
that we have in terms of the different
layers that Council has identified not
just in terms of the impact of our
parishes but for our Ward boundary to
the County Council boundaries and so it
is something that has a degree of
complexity to it this isn't really the
Forum in which I think we should be
looking backwards in terms of what has
what hasn't happened but totally take on
board at the points the councilors are
making and that we need to make sure
that we get this right and I forget who
raised it now but I think it's cancer
scarf in terms of learning the lessons
absolutely that needs to happen
appreciate fully at the Mojo office is
in a position tonight to say these are
the lessons that have been learned not
least because the report is before you
tonight that needs to be considered but
absolutely that we will take that away
and make sure that the residual of this
process and any future Community
governance reviews are managed in a
completely different way
thank you councilor Mathison yeah thank
you chair yeah looking looking to the to
the Future not the past
um oh lost it the um in the
supplementary papers 4.2
um there's a list of things that
our own governance review can do and a
couple of things that it can't do but
surely the other thing that it can't do
ought to be there as well which is
change the world boundaries
it's not it's not on the list but it
would be good if it was what is you know
is that setting out the work plan for
the for the next attempt isn't it really
um I'll go to councilor Otten
please chairman
um I'm not sure whether I need to move
an amendment to be recommendations
because I think everybody will agree to
appendix a there's no contention on on
that at all so if if it needs I need to
move a recommendation it would be that
the council agrees recommendations a and
that count a recommendation 3-2 is
deferred thank you I'd so move
I'm happy to
have happy to slot and some element
okay so um
shall we debate that Amendment that's
just been made would anyone like to um
be involved in that
if I could just see Clarity from Council
Lawton as to the meaning of what she
means by deferred so do you mean
consideration of it this evening
deferred or the community governance
review itself deferred that because the
the meaning of the recommendation is
drafted is that that Community
government's review needs to continue as
the monitoring officers set out so I'm
not sure whether or not you're talking
about deferring the entirety of the work
which monitor officer would say we
shouldn't be doing or simply deferring
your consideration here of it which I
suspect is fine but I will ask Mr alley
to comment on that
I think you understand what I'm talking
I'm sorry what I'm saying is I think we
could easily agree recommendations a and
that the council
just agree that the work needs and we do
not discuss the implications of
recommendation 3.2
question officer to clarify exactly what
that means for what we do in your
business here I think uh just just to
clarify where we are at the moment is
community governance review has begun
and it hasn't come to a conclusion yet
so 3.2 all that's doing is say we'll
just carry on
but we're already there we're already
going to carry on if 3.2
.2 third
we're still going to carry on the
government's review this we've still got
the the impetus to get on with it we
still required to get on with it
so I'm I'm 14 I don't don't quite
understand why
um
be made by three point
deferling three point
three points yeah just to just to check
is everybody looking at the latest
version of this report the supplementary
papers recommendation 3.2 because the
original copy of this
um was worded differently councilor
Mansell
well I am looking at the
the amended things
I think it's red text on it I'm pretty
sure that is the one I'm meant to be
looking at now if I can just clarify
this situation that maybe I'm misreading
cancer rotten but 3.2 says the council
note the reason that the community
governance review were unable to
complete the review which is ongoing
that is just a noting thing and and I
think she's right that we don't really
want to go into the details about why
um
we don't want to note the reason right
now we're not ready to do that because I
think we need a bit more explanation but
yes of course it will still be ongoing
because it's still ongoing but the the
statement says note the reason and I
don't think we're in a position to note
the reason I think we need a little bit
more clarity and a little bit more
information before we can fully
understand the reasons of what's
happened so that's why I'm prepared to
Second uh the amendment I'm not saying
we we stop doing what we're doing in the
community governance review team
um but I don't think we're in a position
to note it properly
maybe I can just help you as I
understand it maybe I'm being very
Agricultural and simple about this what
we were told Beginning by the monitoring
officer that the reviewers continue it
hasn't finished and surely that's what
we want to happen now I don't know what
the timeline is for that but surely for
goodness sake and I just absolutely
understand what everybody's saying there
is a bit of confusion here but the main
principle here is the review must
continue and presumably
people can still put in their comments
um objections suggestions I don't know
whatever it is in order to come to a set
of statutory Solutions what I don't
think
um would jeopardize that is if we're
only noting something I mean I'm not
over bothered one way or the other but I
do think it's important this work
continues doesn't come to a shuddering
Halt and then we get delayed and then
there'll be all sorts of other arguments
I think it's important it's done we move
it forward at PACE
and as I understand it please correct me
if I'm wrong that's really what the
recommendation says and all just noting
about the reason well that's fine it
doesn't mean you have to agree or you
can agree or disagree doesn't it does it
really matter so as long as it's going
forwards and carrying on what is the
problem
thank you very much chair um I entirely
agree with councilor Passmore and I was
going to make a similar note and the
recommendation 3.2 is as it's currently
written is just we note the reason and
obviously acknowledge the fact that the
review is ongoing so to defer the noting
um of the reason
um I think it's splitting hairs as far
as I'm concerned we've all acknowledged
that the uh this is an ongoing process
an ongoing review and so if it helps
move on the debates and helps move this
to vote this is the proposer um so that
I don't accept the amendment and would
like to vote on firstly that Amendment
and then on the recommendations that
we've got in front of us
chairman I'm happy to know are we I'll
um
thank you very much councilor Mansell do
you agree to that as well
um well I um I'm I'm not sure because I
I don't think we need a council decision
as to whether the community governance
review continues that's already in
process we don't need to decide now
whether we're going to carry on it will
carry on unless we decide otherwise if
I've got that right we've already
started the process we don't need a
council decision to say we're going to
carry on I'm not convinced I'm happy
with the with the reason so I'm guessing
that if the amendment is is to be
withdrawn I would like the two
statements to be separated and we take a
vote on 3.1 and then we take a vote on
3.2
yeah yeah okay so um the way of dealing
with this I think is to split this vote
into
3.1 and 3.2
and we'll vote individually on those
items
um we'll just give the team a chance to
set that up on the um on the voting if
everyone's happy with that
so that's that's already set up so thank
you very much
um we'll go through to um Council scarf
sorry chair I mean I just wanted to ask
I mean if the review is ongoing and it
hasn't actually completed within the
deadline of 12 months what is the legal
position for this Council
if they don't compete within the 12
months are there any implications for
this Council in terms of
non-determination of the review I don't
think we have the information in front
of us tonight uh I mean personally I
would vote against
um
8.2 even even as amended because I'm
concerned that the council leaves itself
open
if a party at a later date
then has qualms to issue some kind of
legal process against us as a council
where exactly are we are we at you know
it's it's non-determination it's almost
on the bounds of male Administration by
this Council so where exactly where
exactly are we because I can't see how
you can have an ongoing review which has
a deadline of 12 months
perhaps I can get some clarity on that
thank you um cancer scarf and I'll go to
the monitoring officer for clarity
if you don't complete within the
12-month period
the the rear we are ongoing so therefore
it will be a a more straightforward
challenge the alternative would be to
turn around and say well actually we're
not completing the review tonight we're
finishing that's it we're going to take
Stone Market and one house in
battersford they're going to be done in
2025 now these are decisions that could
be made
I advised against it because of the
12-month rule but you could do that stop
it right now there will be a challenge
there potentially judicial review making
a decision without having all the
information in front of the I.E not
proper consultant
either way
um the damned if we do we're damned if
we don't
usually use that phrase in full Council
but that's that's where you are as I say
my advice has been
let's do it let's do it properly
we are where we are again another phrase
that I've not used in full Council
before
um I can't think of a third one that
I've never used in food Council um
so so the legal challenge can come the
legal challenge is costly and it'll be
costly to the authority as well to
defend it we would be able to defend it
on the basis that we are proceeding We
are continuing we haven't stopped
if we were to stop I think the challenge
would be more effective
it would be a better challenge if we
were to decide not to do
the rationale for values if you complete
a community government's review
a district-wide one
you can't then you don't no one can then
petition you for another two years for a
boundary review or for a boundary review
for any any
um Community governance review so you're
effectively stopping the whole district
from putting in another request for
change to council numbers change to
anything for two years
so that's
just so that's kind of the rationale for
saying we'll carry on with the review
we've got completed and
um and if there is a challenge to be to
be made then those interested parties
will just have to make the challenge
right thank you is there any more
discussion that people want to have
councilor War boys
thank you chair I'm thoroughly confused
now actually
um
from my perspective are reviewers being
carried out it's shown that some things
can be done some things can't be done
uh within the time scale of the review
and this is regard to boundary changes
which need to go up to the boundary
commission which will take
an unspecified amount of time
so the review has been surely completed
in that it's shown what can be done what
needs to be done and
what needs to be acted on we don't have
an ongoing review
for I I don't understand quite the
reason for having an ongoing review
I'll um bring the monitoring officer
into the debate because I think that
needs to be clarified if I can just
explain the the rationale so
when you're dealing with
it's a consultation at the council's
discretion that consultation was just
asked the parish councils what do you
want they said this is what they want
you look at the number of electors
on down you decrease the numbers it's a
more straightforward
consultation if you like
now with regards to a boundary change
you've got potentially new developments
you've got a five-year you've got to
look at the five-year supply of Housing
and how that's going to come out to the
next five years worth of developments
you need to take you need to review
those you need to take those into
account that hasn't happened yet
and so you've got to look at the next
five years so the working group that's
what they'll be looking at they'll be
looking at the next five years of review
in terms of stay market and one house
that's the stretch of land all across
the bottom
that's that's all open to development
now that five-year review of that has to
be taken into account you can't just so
and there are residents that are coming
online people and moving into those uh
properties they're being built and
moving in there are
um I say residents Association actually
residents who have not been consulted
and it's a bit more consultation than
just a letter saying what would you like
that's how the review started
on the back of a petition is what would
you like
so it requires more and that's the
rationale for saying we just continued
but with the wider and better
consultation and adequate
thank you Council scarf
thank you Mr thank you for allowing me
to come back
um I think I have to make the point at
this juncture that the Town Council
Stone Market Town Council asked for a
community Government review of this
Council
for March 2022 in fact there's uh
evidence uh paperwork uh Etc going back
to 2018. we were told as a Town Council
we could not have that Community
government's review until there was a
district-wide
government
had the issue been dealt with then
none of the people living in the
distributed boundary between Stone
Market and one house would have been
affected because none of the houses
would have actually been there the
boundary would have been concluded one
way or the other whichever way that it's
going to go before the physical houses
were there now to fit some of the
physical houses are there you are going
to get into the situation where
residents really do need some clear
explanation of what the implications are
are for them clearly there are two
different Parish precepts
clearly is a case of where residents
look to for the services that are
provided my argument would be that
residents of that disputed area next
at a moment we'll look to the Parish of
snow market for a lot of their services
and Facilities yet stowmarket will not
receive any monies from that area and
that could well be the same with
batsford and Coombs I'm not really aware
aware of that so it's okay so where
residents look to for the provision of
services
that review could have been carried out
earlier and that that I think that point
does need to be made we're not talking
about the review that started in March
22 we're talking about a delayed review
that Stone Market Town Council asked for
many years ago and in fact conversations
between the Town Council and the
district council over the union road
development have been going for nearly
10 years it is identified in The Stone
Market area action plan
need I say more it's being sold as Stone
Market residents won't think they're in
a different area they'll think they're
part of Stone Market it's going to be so
confusing for residents and I think this
council could have done a great deal
more to get things going and this is a
this is a really poor example of this
Council failing the residents of mid
Suffolk
thank you very much councilman Mansell
you've already spoken in debate once is
this I just think that some of what
councilor scarf was referring to I don't
think he's up for debate
and I'm not sure it's relevant and I
just thought I didn't think it was thank
you very much to be putting those points
across right thank you
um
councilor wellum
yeah I'll be very very quick
um 3.2 is Council note the reason in
appendix B but I think the monitoring
offer officer has said he doesn't fully
know what the reasons are so it does
make sense to completely withdraw 3.2
because you're asking us to agree the
reason set out in appendix B but the
monitoring Officer says there may be
other reasons so why don't we just drop
I I invite the proposal of the sector to
drop 3.2 we just wrote on 3.1 I'm quite
happy at this stage to put this to the
vote
um as it is
separately separately we'll we'll
separate these two take it to the vote
now
um and um then deal with the results of
that vote
thanks
okay so if the proposal and the
secondary were willing to withdraw 3.2
you could do that now
your discretion
yes chair if the monetary officer is
happy with that then I'm happy to
withdraw recommendations I could have
done that half an hour ago
okay thank you very much so we will take
that to the um vote now
um
there'll be there's two up there but
we're asking you now to vote on 3.1 and
not on 3.2 at any point in this meeting
um councilor Carter we we have gone to
the vote is it essential
may I take my vote verbally I did very
much I can pretty much like my own
batteries I'm afraid my laptop has died
right
is this the point of order councilor
sorry
by the governance and Civic office to
conduct the
electronic vote sure so thank you we
have now withdrawn 3.2 so you um
councils can you cast your vote for 3.1
thank you
thank you and councilor Fleming Paul
um
Mason do you want to put your vote
through oh it's gone through has it oh
brilliant
so chair that is 32 votes four and one
against
okay thank you very much that's carried
so we'll um we'll move on to item 12 on
the agenda which is mc2232 special
urgent decisions taken by officers under
delegated powers in accordance with part
two of The Constitution so for this I'd
like to invite the chief executive to
thank you chairman I'm noting from the
rustling that members would like me to
be brief so I will be
um you will be aware that it's the
responsibility to report back to this
Council where any decisions are needed
to be taken under delegated powers uh
particularly as a matter of urgency that
has occurred in this particular case and
I'll read the right
legislation regulations so the smoke and
carbon monoxide alarm Amendment
regulations 2022 came into force on the
first of October last year that requires
us to make sure that we have smoke
alarms and carbon monoxide detectors in
all of our properties our current
contraction arrangement in place didn't
enable us to be able to deliver that
swiftly enough and so we've emptied into
a separate contract as uh mentioned
within the report to make sure that we
can comply and ensure that our tenants
are protected through the installation
of those detectors as soon as possible
thank you very much
um this report some for noting
so unless anyone's got any questions on
Clarity councilor Fleming
um yes thank you and I'm sorry I do have
a question because
um this decision was made in the
beginning of December with um
the detectors Etc to be installed by the
end of January which is quite a short
time and there's no mention in the
background document about how many new
devices will need to be acquired and
what the division of goods versus
Services is that the 150 000 is going to
um so I do I do think you know I'm sure
it's all Grand and it was the right
decision but just that breakdown would
be helpful so that we we know that
office of decisions made in that way are
made correctly
thank you do you have that information
to hand I do in terms of the numbers
that needed to be installed and I know
that good progress is being made I can't
give you the figure as of today but I
can certainly give you the figure as in
what needed to be done so in terms of
the carbon monoxide detectors that's
3078 that were required and in terms of
the smoke detectors that was
2937 that we required so a big piece of
work clearly to be going into
essentially every single one of our
tenanted properties and installing those
uh detectors for our tenants
thank you very much and I assume that
these will be um serviced using air and
services rather than signics
thank you very much counselor Eben
um thank you chair can I just ask is
this to do with the new regulations from
the social housing regulator that we now
need to comply with and if so were there
further compliance issues that we all
need to be spending
um more for more money on or looking at
other contracts thank you thank you the
chief executive yes so as I mentioned
earlier this links to the 2022
regulations it's always what I say
always for many years been the case for
the private sector that's been extended
to the public sector so this is part and
parcel of strengthening uh safety and
health and safety and security for
tenants off the back of the grenfell
disaster but obviously going much more
widely than that in terms of will there
be further compliance issues in the
future I suspect they will because I
firmly suspect without having uh the
prevented in the room but I firmly
suspect that the government's direction
of travel and any government's
directional travel in relation to health
and safety matters for tenants will be
to keep strengthening and raising the
bar and therefore we will have further
work to do in the future I'm sure you
and I'm sure you will all be Keen to not
only make sure that we comply with the
minimum if you like in terms of what the
legislation requires of us but also to
go as far as possible to make sure that
all of our tenants live in safe homes
thank you very much and councilor
Whitehead it's okay I just asked the
chief executive um the numbers in terms
of
um smoke detectors and CO2 were they
Vapor animals obvious look over because
if there were baby animal server gets
about 50 who admit typically it's
probably more than 90 of our property is
that right
so the figures I gave you were just
mid-suffix figures fair to say that if
you add on the baby figures essentially
it's double
thank you very much and I'll conclude
conclusome report like I said before
it's for noting and move on to item 13
which is counselor appointment are there
any changes in place in
no thank you very much
motions on notice
thank you very much and the date of the
next meeting is Thursday the 23rd of
February
at 5 30 p.m and I'll um conclude this
meeting at 8 15.